the next assassin's creed game has
vikings cliff blezinski is revving up
for
something new and dying light is rising
from the dead
i'm kurt and you have made it to your
saved state for wednesday april 29th
grab yourself a horn and pour some meat
in it because the next assassin's creed
has got vikings artist boss logic
streamed a new art project and when all
was said and done it confirmed that the
next assassin's creed game
has a viking theme of course there were
previously rumors circulating it be a
viking setting
and the two vikings fighting with icy
ships and all certainly prove those
rumors to be
true we'll know more about the next
assassin's creed game very soon as
ubisoft ended the stream by setting up
another imminent reveal
do vikings wear hoods and do parkour let
me know
i'm asking for somebody else who wants
to know not me
the machine gun chainsaw wielding king
himself cliffy b
of gears of war lawbreakers and radical
heights fame is
back in the creator's chair working on
something
i don't think he knows either he went on
to twitter saying quote
i'm noodling on a new ip during this
lockdown i don't know what it'll wind up
being
a movie or game or graphic novel or tv
series but
i'm working sounds like a lot and well i
hope he does it all
including finishing his autobiography
where is it cliffy b
where is your autobiography anyways
nonetheless i just hope he does another
musical that'd be sweet what do you
think he'll do next
let us know some things just refuse to
die
and in this case it's for the better
dying light dev techland is resurrecting
hellraid
a co-op demon fighting game it was also
making for turning it into dlc for dying
light
originally helleraid was planned for the
ps3 and xbox 360 back in 2013
and then it was delayed to 2015 and then
well
it was put on hold to not meeting
internal expectations
but no longer it looks like it'll be
seeing daylight this summer's paid dlc
anyways meanwhile teclan continues the
work on dying light 2
and a new ip do you think this will hold
you over
epic continues to throw out free games
like dabs
and fortnite but with a catch in order
to claim them
you're now required to enable a
two-factor authentication on your
account
this is in place until at least may 21st
but really this is probably for the best
epic was sued for a security breach last
year and this seems like the right move
starting april 30th epic's free games
are going to be crash lands and amnesia
the dark descent which
i never finished because i'm a coward
don't be me anyways that's all the
exciting news that happened today but
there's always that and a whole lot more
you can read and learn about at
gamespot.com
again i'm kurt feel free to bug me
whenever your heart desires on twitter
at curt
underscore indovina see you at
tomorrow's
safe state
you